[Musica]
un milione di miglia in volo all'anno
destinazione 60 paesi nel mondo
lunedi venerdi tutte le settimane per
oltre 20 anni
è stato un percorso fantastico
non tanto per ciò che ho visto ma perché
ho incontrato persone eccezionali con
cui ho vissuto condiviso dei momenti
bellissimi ma anche quelli difficili che
abbiamo affrontato insieme sempre e ci
siamo divertiti tantissimo
e oltre ad aver apprezzato la bellezza
della diversità delle culture ho capito
chiaramente che ci sono cose che
funzionano
ovunque e cose che semplicemente non
ho capito innanzitutto c'è una cosa in
comune noi siamo tutti persone
ea volte lo dimentichiamo
e il nostro essere umani ci porta ad
accettare o rifiutare delle
sollecitazioni
esattamente allo stesso modo
ovunque nel mondo
e poi ovunque vai il successo delle
aziende decretato dalle persone le
persone fanno la differenza e allora
circa due anni fa dopo 20 anni nella
prima nazionale della multinazionale del
lavoro
ho deciso di lasciare per creare
un'azienda insieme a dei fondi che
mettesse al centro il suo patrimonio
principale le persone
volevo addirittura a creare aziende non
per i clienti ma per le persone che ci
lavorano
fare in modo che la loro natura non
fosse combattuta ma liberata
il tutto il suo meraviglioso potenziale
oggi dopo i due anni siamo 636
dipendenti abbiamo 120 uffici in italia
nel rennes che sia una grande azienda ma
ci sentiamo piccolissimi perché
guardiamo lontano
e quando crei un azienda per le persone
che ci lavorano
e un po come quando eravamo ragazzi
innamorati
il nostro primo appuntamento e allora
sceglievamo il ristorante più bello il
tavolo ci mettevamo le nostre cose più
carine perché volevamo che quella sera
fosse indimenticabile allo stesso modo
noi scegliamo un nome un brand che possa
piacere alle persone che verranno a
lavorare con noi degli uffici nei posti
dove loro pensiamo che il loro vogliono
andare e lì arrediamo in modo piacevole
bello dove la loro professionalità sia
riflessa dove si possa creare un
ecosistema dove ci si diverte
cerchiamo di definire una cultura
importantissimo che sia in linea con i
loro valori e dargli un sogno a cui
ispirarsi e organizzarla in maniera
semplice perché noi umani vogliamo la
semplicità avere un capo pochi obiettivi
che siano raggiungibili perché vogliamo
avere successo e ribaltarla
l'organizzazione mettere le persone che
sono a contatto con i clienti
al top e noi siamo dietro a supportarli
e che si scelgano fra loro perché devono
lavorare insieme si devono divertire
insieme le persone non lasciano le
aziende le persone lasciano le persone
e alla fine è questione di fiducia
questa parola
oggi tutti parliamo di dati e pensiamo
che i dati siano l'olio che consentirà a
tutti di crescere molto più velocemente
e vero ma tra le persone la fiducia è il
cemento
e la fiducia si costruisce col tempo
conoscendosi nei nostri punti di forza e
soprattutto nei nostri punti di
debolezza
perché siamo stufi di persone che sono
si pretendono di essere perfetto di
aziende che non vogliono sbagliare
neanche uno e lo pretendono le loro
persone siamo umani vogliamo sbagliare
insieme vogliamo andare avanti insieme
vogliamo poter contare l'uno dell'altro
vogliamo lasciar non lasciare nessuno
indietro mai
alla fine
e facile no
se hai delle persone fantastiche
raggiungerai dei risultati straordinari
saranno loro a definire le strategie
vincenti saranno loro a differenziare il
tuo servizio saranno loro a fare in modo
che i tuoi clienti avranno un'esperienza
eccezionale e saranno loro e sarà solo
merito loro quando raggiungeranno dei
risultati straordinari
e il mio ruolo è molto facile andare in
giro e fare in modo che loro si sentono
addosso la fiducia di prendere decisioni
adesso è andare avanti senza paura di
sbagliare
chi non fa non sbaglia bisogna essere
fieri dei propri errori e dichiararli ho
sbagliato ma dobbiamo andare avanti
il mio ruolo è andare ascoltare se hanno
bisogno se hanno bisogno di qualche
strumento della formazione di un
consiglio a volte di una decisione ma
soprattutto andare in giro a celebrarli
perché noi tutti vogliamo essere
apprezzati
e perché mai dovremmo risparmiarci un
grazie
e quando crei un azienda per le persone
che ci lavorano di essere molto attento
alle parole e vi faccio un esempio
il mondo sta cambiando tutto è cambiato
cambiato come consumiamo come viviamo
come viviamo la nostra giornata e le
aziende si parla di trasformation re
engineering
ma se io chiedessi a voi qui voi volete
cambiare
voi volete trasformarvi
veramente
beh il primo approccio di solito è sì io
sono aperto al cambiamento il passato è
il passato
guardo avanti sono pronto allora in cosa
come devo cambiare però prima dopo un po
ci rendiamo conto priva del cane dimmi
come dovrei essere in futuro bionda
occhi azzurri o biondo il sempre
piaciuto tantissimo occhi azzurri e ci
rendiamo conto che la è che non vogliamo
cambiare
ma se io adesso vi chiedessi voi volete
evolvere
sì non c'è da pensare
siamo esseri umani vogliamo andare
avanti eravamo bambini siamo adulti
siamo trasformati
siamo semplicemente voluti abbiamo nuova
app sul telefono cambiamo non facciamo
più delle cose che facevamo di ieri
andiamo avanti e devolviamo
e quando crei un azienda per le persone
che ci lavorano devi essere umile
perché hai la certezza che le migliori
idee non verranno mai la te
perché vuoi guardare le persone non
ricercando quello che vuoi trovare tu ma
cercando cosa c'è di bello dentro di
loro cosa c'è di positivo e partire da
lì
perché vuoi ammettere i tuoi punti di
debolezza e trovare chi ti può
complementare
perché se sei umile ascolti ascolti
veramente
l'umiltà chi ha buone orecchie a mille
occhi l'umiltà non è debolezza
anzi
e quando crei un azienda per le persone
che ci lavorano
devi gestire con il cuore
ci sono i numeri ci sono i risultati ma
le decisioni vanno prese con il cuore
perché siamo tutti persone e quando
magari dobbiamo prendere decisioni
difficili a volte sono necessari
non ci dobbiamo dormire la notte
ed è un po come in amore io sono sposato
da 25 anni e ti scopri scopri cosa
significa quando vedi che adori i suoi
punti di debolezza i suoi difetti
non li sopporti non li subisce ci
sorride e così anche nella vita del
lavoro sorridiamo sulle debolezze degli
altri e su quelle dell'azienda e
prendiamoci cosa c'è di buono
e mettiamoci la magia
la magia
non è far tanto e quella ciliegina sulla
torta che però fa tutta la differenza e
quel folle far sentire le persone
speciali e basta a volte solo porsi la
domanda cosa posso fare per renderlo
farlo sentire speciale
e dobbiamo focalizzarci sul percorso
sapete quando si ha una grande azienda
c'è sempre un nuovo progetto che parte
una nuova ambizione un nuovo sogno è di
solito questi sogni si posizionano sulle
montagne le montagne più alte l'everest
bellissime innevate con un cielo azzurro
spettacolare e tutti quanti noi che
siamo qui vogliamo arrivare lì sarà
fantastico e abbiamo tutto abbiamo gli
strumenti abbiamo le competenze siamo
noi siamo una squadra ci aiuteremo noi
potremmo arrivare lì possiamo ci
arriveremo
certo dovremo affrontare le tempeste le
avversità le difficoltà
sarà dura cia faticheremo tantissimo ma
quando arriveremo sulla montagna sarà
bellissimo guarderemo il mondo da
un'altra prospettiva
potremmo festeggiarci con una bandiera e
farci delle foto a meno 35 gradi e poi
scendere basta noi vogliamo divertirci
vivere ogni giorno
vogliamo avere un sogno ma ammettiamolo
alle maldive e ogni giorno divertiamoci
perché il lavoro e passione e gioire di
quello che facciamo e soprattutto la
cosa piu importante e con chi lo
facciamo noi scegliamo le aziende
scegliamo le persone con cui noi
lavoreremo e allora mia domanda è ma voi
vi divertite
divertiamoci grazie
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]